ايران على صفيح ساخن الاحتجاجات في
الشوارع ضد السلطات وازمه اقتصاديه خانقه
تضرب البلاد النظام المالي على شفل انهيار
ان لم يكن انهار فعلا 10 سفن التجاريه
المحمله بالمواد الغذائيه عالقه قباله
الموانئ الايرانيه بعد تاخرها لاسابيع
مشكله الدفع تعطل تدفق البضائع
البيانات اظهرت عدم قدره السفن على تفريغ
شحنتها ما لا يقل عن اربعين ناقله سائبه
عالقه خارج من اي بندر الخميني وبندر عباس
وهما من الموانئ الايرانيه الرئيسيه منظمه
الموانئ والملاحه البحريه الايرانيه قالت
ان نحو 37 سفينه تحمل مليونين ومئتي الف
طن من الفضائع لم تتمكن من تفريغ حمولاتها
بسبب عوائق خاصه بالمستندات والسداد
بالعمله الصعبه القوى الغربيه اعفت الموا
ضد الغذائيه من عقوباتها المفروضه على
ايران بسبب برنامجها النووي لكن تاثير
العقوبات على النظام المالي الايراني جعل
تسديد ايران لمدفوعتها للشركات الدوليه
امرا معقدا
ويمثل الامن الغذائي اولويه بالنسبه
لايران ازاله الحاجه الى الواردات
الغذائيه بسبب الجفاف الذي اضر بانتاج
الغذاء المحلي لموسمين متتاليين لكن
استمرار الازمه السياسيه الخانقه يجعل
النظام عاجزا عن توفير اساسيه الحياه ما
يهدد بسقوطه وفق خبراء بلال البوجدين
العربيه